Hi zusammen!
Heute gibt's Blätterteig-Teilchen mit Pudding
auf die schnelle Art, auf die einfache Art
und natürlich wie immer auf die leckere Art!
Ihr findet die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Ich lege direkt los,
ich benutze heute tiefgekühlten Blätterteig.
Den gibt's in der quadrat-  nee, nicht quadrat-
in der rechteckigen Form!
Habe ich jetzt hier 10min lang auftauen lassen
damit er ein bisschen weicher wird.
Und jetzt nehme ich mir mein Pizzarad
und schneide das jeweils in der Hälfte einmal durch.
Die Blätterteige dann auf das mit Backpapier ausgelegte
Backblech tun und mit Wasser bepinseln.
Das machen wir deshalb damit unser Zucker daran haften bleibt.
Ich hab' auch wirklich nur ein bisschen Zucker genommen,
also wirklich nur so ungefähr ½TL pro Quadrat.
Und jetzt wandern die Blätterteige in den Backofen.
Ich nehme diesmal Umluft, 190° C.
Umluft ist deshalb gut weil Blätterteig soll ja eben so ein bisschen austrocknen und knusprig werden.
Und ich sage euch dann im Anschluss, wie lange sie bei mir gebraucht haben.
So, nach 12min sind sie perfekt durchgebacken
Und jetzt einfach stehen lassen und auskühlen lassen.
Und ich kümmere mich solange um die Füllung, ich mache jetzt einen leckeren Vanillepudding.
Da habe ich hier schon alles vorbereitet.
Und zwar benötigen wir auch nur 4 Zutaten:
Milch, Speisestärke, Zucker und Vanilleextrakt.
Das war's! Ich verrühre jetzt auch alles im Topf.
Den Herd noch nicht einschalten, erst klümpchenfrei verrühren
und dann schalte ich den Herd ein und lasse das schön eindicken.
Den eingedickten Vanillepudding dann kurz umfüllen,
direkt an der Oberfläche abdecken
und vollständig auskühlen lassen.
Bei mir ist er jetzt vollständig ausgekühlt
und das Coole ist, dass man hier auch kein Ei braucht.
Also ihr habt normalerweise im Pudding Eigelb,
dann wisst ihr nicht, was ihr mit dem Eiweiß machen sollt..
das fällt hier komplett weg!
Ich geb' das jetzt hier in meine Maschine.
Das geht auch mit dem Schneebesen,
dann müsst ihr nur richtig Kraft anwenden
Und in der Maschine braucht es jetzt nur so ½min
dass ich das einmal fluffig schlage
und dann fülle ich das um in einen Spritzbeutel.
Ich hab' jetzt übrigens ne Fülltülle vorne dran, ich find' das immer am einfachsten
weil das hat diese feine Spitze.
Ihr müsst dann quasi nur durch die Blätterteig-Teilchen stechen und dann den Pudding einfüllen.
Und es macht auch richtig Spaß, also das ist mein persönlicher Lieblingspart!
So, als nächstes werden wir Zartbitterkuvertüre temperieren.
Ihr könntet auch - wenn ihr keine Zartbitter-Fans seid, könnt ihr auch Vollmilch nehmen.
Ist auch gar kein Thema! Ich hab' jetzt hier einen Topf mit heißem Wasser einmal aufkochen lassen,
dann abgeschaltet. Habe ich jetzt hier vorliegen
und obendrüber eine feuerfeste Schüssel. Bitte nehmt 'ne feuerfeste Schüssel!
Damals, als ich noch unerfahren war, habe ich mal eine Schüssel darüber gegeben,
die nicht feuerfest war und dann könnt ihr euch vorstellen, was passiert ist!
Auf jeden Fall werde ich jetzt 2/3 der Kuvertüre hier drin schmelzen über dem Wasserbad
und nehme es dann runter und gebe 1/3 mit dazu.
Also ihr splittet quasi die Gesamtmenge einmal auf, damit ihr später keinen Grauschleier habt.
Also bei der Deko könnt ihr frei entscheiden.
Ich hab' mich da gerade mit der weißen Schokolade noch so ein bisschen ausprobiert.
Ansonsten könnt ihr das auch klassisch lassen. Ihr könntet's auch mit Puderzucker beschreiben
aber ich finde, dass die Schokolade das Ganze nochmal richtig abrundet!
Und wir zwei, wir gönnen uns das jetzt, ne?
(H: M-hm!)
Kaffee dazu, schön auf dem Balkon sitzen und dann einfach nur gönnen!
(H: Darf ich heute was sagen?)
Klar!
(H: Heute siehst du besonders hübsch aus!)
Neiiin!
(H: Doch!)
Nein!
(H: Doch, ehrlich!)
Ehrlich?
(H: Nicht rot werden! Komm, mach weiter)!
Okay!
Also ich finde euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen
und wir sehen uns dann bei meinem nächsten Rezept, bei meinem nächsten Vlog
oder bei der zweiten Folge Kikis Kitchen Hacks, die kommt nämlich bald!
(H: Oder bei einem XXL-Video, wir werden's ja sehen!)
Oder bei einem XXL-Video mal wieder!
Also bis dann, Tschüss!